how do you look at early stage we at
cyan up yesterday obviously sayin and I
came up as angel investors together your
you started as an angel investor we're
talking last night I had a discussion
about how the field has changed you guys
have really changed the game in venture
capital what's what's your approach to
early stage and working with angels oh
we love it I mean again so venture
capital comes down to three well four
things and I'll get into why I don't
think number four is that important but
it comes down to do you see the right
deals can you pick the right deals can
you get into their ideals and then part
four is do you help the company you know
after you're in the deal and I actually
think that's the least important part
and I can get into why later but those
first three parts are ridiculously
important so all that we do with the
angel community in cyan is actually
leading this you know for us is so
important because there's no way as
individuals you can see everything and
people in this audience people all
around are going to see things that we
would never otherwise see that are not
in our backyard that are not in our
fields of expertise but that could still
be ridiculously good companies and so
that's it's such a we we embrace that
tsiyon is like having an event but these
people live with people like this is a
huge part of the ecosystem is angel
investing it's very important when do
you want to see a company so you know I
when we see each other and run into each
other at the movies or something and you
feel like so what are you working on and
like what's what companies do you like
and I give you two of them there
immediately in your office and you're
meeting with them in the next two weeks